Brian Urlacher Hall of Famer and former
NFL Defensive Player of the Year he
joins us on behalf of the FanDuel sports
book at blue chip Casino Hotel and Spa
that's in Michigan City Indiana opens
today FanDuel sports book at blue chip
casino the largest sports book outside
of Las Vegas and Brian's gonna place the
ceremonial first wager there I'm
assuming you're wagering on the Bears
Brian yeah Daniel right I will be I will
be wagering on the Bears tonight correct
have you ever bet on a sporting event
before yes would you bet on college
football are you any good
no well I don't know any good at reading
it's uh it's hard man but no I don't do
good at all how much did you bet I don't
remember and who'd you bet on so I had
to be like mm my boy Texas Tech with
squirrels points back in the day yeah
and so I took their team over and I
think their quarterback I heard so yeah
if you want something to go bad have you
been happy bet on your team your
guarantee loose which Gramm Harold the
quarterback back then it might have been
grand we're like 57 points and and they
gave up like 48 games I was taking over
82 is a deal when it comes to Aaron
Rodgers in Matt Lafleur and much has
been made in the offseason about being
able to call audibles or how much power
does Aaron Rodgers have Aaron Rodgers
doesn't strike me as an audible guy did
you did you play him thinking he was
changing them any place at the line of
scrimmage you know what I think he just
got some of the best play possible he
reads do so well I guess out there he
has a play they obviously call play and
holler or two plays and he goes was the
best one but yes I think he did change
it quite a bit you know just because you
don't want to run a play into a defense
that's not gonna work against so you
know change it at the line of scrimmage
and I don't see why he wouldn't have
that power right now do the same thing
he's so good at it and it knows exactly
what defense you're in every time so
we're not getting successful play but
how often did you guess right with Aaron
Rodgers well we just read cover to every
play we
you know even if they were check-in or
whatever there be sometimes we were in a
blitz oh we would have man coverage
called and he'd be checking I'm like
they're going to a pass they're gonna do
to cover its cover too so we would uh
most of our checks we're going to cover
two and there was some times where we
could go from two to one but you're just
putting yourself in danger if we do that
against that guy so we we still have a
cover to most of time we did pretty good
how often did you talk to him or he
talked to you during a game pretty often
you know between plays quite often uh I
don't know five four five six times and
you got 300 timeouts a game so you know
you get we get those those times in
there as well yeah I I don't know
because it doesn't strike me as he would
trash talk to you but it's more of like
um maybe a business relationship not a
lot of trash on going on you're right
but it was and I wouldn't say business
just I think it was just fun honestly we
both had a good time where and Lance was
the same way Lance would jump in there
all the time as well but it was I
wouldn't say business but it was mostly
mostly fun banter going back and forth
did it quarterback ever talk smack to
you remember you know remember ear
Brooks yes yeah I mean they came back we
had him down twenty20 in Champaign 23-0
in Champaign in 2002 I think they came
back and beers like 23 20 and he was
yappin in the whole second half so that
was frustrating cuz we couldn't stop so
didn't really matter but I don't have
any idea a long time ago what do you
miss about the game my teammates my
coaches being in the facility being in
me and much as much as I hated meetings
I said like I still miss them just all
the stuff that comes with it you know
not necessarily the game or playing the
game just getting ready for games was
always fun to me you wore a cowboy
jacket during an interview at the Pro
Bowl last year yes what the hell were
you doing
so it was raining I don't know if you
watch the probe or I don't know if
anybody doesn't like crazy and we were
we were I was on the cowboy staff that
game I was the captain for the NFC and
they were the coaches so that's all the
ring gear here the Bears didn't send me
any Rangers I wear a Cowboys rain jacket
for the game wait wait wait you're Brian
Urlacher you're you're afraid of the
rain I'm not afraid of the rain but I
like to be dry oh my god you're tough
man everybody thought okay pal oh man
but you said Twitter of fire blaze when
they you were like why does their lunker
got a cowboy jacket on well if you put
two and two together the Cowboys coaches
are coaching the game and they brew they
send all their stuff you know so why
wouldn't I be wearing it
I was driving but the better question is
he's smart because he's dry he leaves
using a jacket to stay dry are you
getting his statue
what well Walter Payton got one your
talent scout one yeah I don't think I
put myself in that category
they're two of the all-time great bears
you know coach and owner and then you
got my favorite bear of all time in
Walter how about an off-ramp it's named
after you my accolades right now so I'll
just pick where I'm at
are you comfortable with the Bears and
they're kicking issues well we're gonna
find out I guess then I know I don't
know anything about the kicker I don't
know I don't know who hears don't know
what's going on I just hopefully we
score touchdowns tonight and it won't be
an issue
do you consider kickers football players
yes they're important I mean if you got
a good one I was very fortunate to
probably gold for probably 10 years or
89 but how many years here in Chicago
and he was good you know we always knew
when the game was on line Robbie was
gonna make it so it's a huge confidence
thing as well but yeah he's a football
player he was at practice every day
working his tail off like everybody else
he's the Hall of Famer Brian Urlacher
joining us on the program if you were
facing Mitchell true Biscay what would
you want him force him to do
whoo that's a good question I don't want
to I don't want him to beat us with his
legs but you know he's doing a good job
as getting rid of
Torche another season their coach nag
you put him in some good situations but
he got rid of the ball pretty quick and
I think this year's gonna he's going to
be even better you know one more year in
the system with coach Daggett tutelage I
see them get a little better this year
and being a being the quarterback that
we drafted
yeah I'm just curious when you're
playing against these quarterbacks you
you have a game plan obviously who's the
guy that you just said no matter what
our game plan was it didn't matter
you know they know what defense you're
in every time these quarter ooh Brees is
great obviously Tom berry Peyton was
great
Aaron Brent was great they know what
defense you're in every single time and
now with all the fake snap counts they
do you know they move their leg they
start moving around back here so you
think they're going to snap it and then
they don't and you did you show your
hand you show them exactly what defense
you're in and that's what they want so
but how does how defeating is it when
you're at the line of scrimmage and all
of a sudden Brady looks over and he
calls out exactly what you guys are in
and so you know necessarily say they're
in this coverage I think they just say I
don't know pay attention I got enough
crap going on a defensive side of all to
worry about what they're saying so um
you know they just know and they do it
now that they work to play clock so well
they get themselves 15 seconds or
whatever and then they'll change it to
arrive before the ball snapped and
you're screwed you guys are stuck in a
bad defense you miss hitting somebody no
heck no you know I every once awhile I
crash in my mountain bike and that
reminds me of how much I felt on Mondays
out there football games your reaction
when you saw that Gronk decided not to
come back and then certainly Andrew Luck
I mean it's a violent game that you play
and even when you get healthy it's not
like you go oh let me go back to playing
football that's why I was unhealthy in
the first place I applaud them both you
know what Gronk went through Super Bowls
great career probably the best idea of
all time or is in the in the in the
conversation as well and Andrew Luck I
was super happy for him you know you
just to go and he's gone through it he
never felt healthy it's a bad cycle to
get into where you just can't get
yourself healthy and you're fighting all
the time to get back on the field and
you're never happened with you when
you're not healthy it's frustrating
so I
I applaud them both for doing that
making that decision it's a hard
decision to make
how would you feel Carli Lloyd was
kicking for your football team
pretty solid she was he kick a 55 yarder
yeah but you know it was awesome but she
had like a 15-yard head start running on
the ball that's true that's true I mean
she made it don't get my butt and I fell
you have like one point two seconds to
kick the ball or you're gonna get
blocked or it's gonna get you're gonna
get tackled if you're the kicker so if
you keep shaking her timing right it
should be great but man she drilled that
thing but also everybody went all which
she's not gonna tackle anybody when's
the last time you talked about a kicker
and you said all but can he tackle
anybody like you know the Zetas or
gramatica is like they're tackling
anybody my kicker has to tackle it we
got other issues you know so I'm not
worried about that the guys aren't
covered you have to make those plays
what is the value of the running back in
today's NFL if you got to go but it's a
big deal you know and a lot of teams do
it by committee now because there are so
many good ones you know and you have to
what the five or six really good ones
but um I mean it's invaluable if you can
run the ball it's such a big thing but
there's a situation in in Dallas and I'm
glad they got it done I think he's such
a big part of our office of what they
can do with the play action game and
just he just starts everything for him
41 and a half sacks 22 interceptions I
think you're one of five players in
history who have had at least 20
interceptions and 40 sacks okay Ray
Lewis is on top there with 31
interceptions 41 you have the same
number of sacks is Ray Lewis okay cool I
don't know wait you mean he has the same
amount number of sacks as I do yeah is
what you mean oh yeah that my bad oh
yeah okay did you measure yourself
against Ray like you you have to feel
you're you're better than Ray Lewis
right like in your mind so there was
there were some seasons why I play
better and there were some seasons he
played better
I just but of course you can play
yourself to the best players in the game
while you're playing you know I would of
course after every game I go I whatever
I do and we Tina I talked about this at
the Hall of Famers he would
same thing he like alright whatever like
I do this gamer and I go back and look
at his stats and it's hard to tell
because the NFL stats are so skewed with
tackles because they don't count you
know I would make a tackle on our guard
I call Lance Briggs on the tackle during
the play after you tackle somebody you
can hear the PA guy hear the guys saying
Oh Lance Briggs are like wait a minute
that was me so you know those tackle
numbers are a little a little skewed but
uh you look for the big place the sacks
the fumbles of cause fumbles the pick
stuff like that but I definitely always
checked on the stats and plus I was a
fan of Ray you know he's a great player
obviously do you remember your last
interception was against to Matt
Hasselbeck me write the chest and I know
your last sack was against two I do not
know I didn't have that information I'm
just curious okay yeah I'm sorry I think
I don't think I had a second in 2012
which is my last year 11 I may have had
a couple I don't know I'm asked a
question by the way the most important
question hell's the hair the hair sweet
yeah going good yeah it grows so fast
when I was a kid my hair grew really
fast and I was always annoyed because I
had to get a haircut like every four
days I felt like cuz I like this short
and now I feel like I'm in the same boat
again when I get a haircut like oh it's
like you need a haircut I just got a
haircut so you know stressful with her
the bus the hall-of-fame bus doesn't
have hair right it does not know I
didn't play football with her yeah yeah
I know I know I didn't know if you said
hey this is how I want to look from now
on no no no I want to be remembered how
I looked when I played yeah you I don't
think you would have been as badass
looking if you had hair back then I'm
just saying the intimidation part like I
don't know anyway doesn't matter but
when you when you don't see our faces or
our hair when you take your helmet off
on the sidelines oh yeah you sleep the
guys from another side are looking like
wow there's a badass-looking at 55 yards
away over they were those helmet off and
he's bald but did you ever envy Clay
Matthews in his hair no I used to used
to annoy me so back
okay you just spray the water on his
face and his aunt always just like run
it around I used to I used to know
everything I guess so like I like clay
but I played against it was annoying hey
good good to talk to you have fun with
the the first the ceremonial first wager
sandal sports book at blue chip Casino
Hotel and Spa in Michigan City Indiana
which opens today thanks Dan thank you
buddy Brian Urlacher Hall of Famer for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]